hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast employing new approaches to
investigate human and mouse group 2
innate lymphoid cell responses i'm judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Vlad roads and
sponsored by ebioscience ebioscience
provides innovative high-quality
reagents to researchers worldwide that
empower the process of scientific
discoveries in the areas of cellular
immunity cell biology and oncology their
extensive portfolio a leading edge cell
analysis products and technologies
focused on flow cytometry and immune
detection position its customers to be
at the forefront of science ebioscience
is aligned with and responsive to its
customers ever-changing needs making
ebioscience a preferred discovery
partner for more information please
visit e bioscience com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in a Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on a
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit a
problem for the green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker will react hate why no
dr. Olea take why no pursues a lifelong
passion for the biological sciences as
an assistant professor at the cornell
university college of veterinary
medicine oviya received her PhD from the
University of Pennsylvania working with
dr. Christopher hunter in the School of
Veterinary Medicine to examine the mecca
isms that promote protective immunity to
the protozoan parasite Toxoplasma gondii
she went on to complete a postdoctoral
fellowship with dr. david artists and
university of pennsylvania Perelman
School of Medicine and wild cornell
medical college focusing on a regulation
on immune responses during helminth
infection and allergic disease as an
assistant professor at the Baker
Institute for Animal Health at Cornell
University she continues to work in
dissecting immunological pathways that
regulate innate immune responses
following helminth parasite infection
and during allergy the special emphasis
on regulations by cytokines and
prostaglandins four games to increase
our understanding of how our immune
system protects us from infection when
it is functioning optimally and how our
immune system can cause inappropriate
information when it becomes
dysfunctional this fork will hopefully
inform efforts to develop new therapies
to combat infectious diseases
particularly diseases caused by parasite
infection and to limit allergic
inflammation I will now turn it over to
miss Leah take one out for her
presentation hi good morning everybody
thank you so much to judy for that kind
introduction i'm very excited to be with
you this morning to talk a little bit
about some of the work that I've done in
recent years looking at a particular
type of innate immune cell called the
group two nite lymphoid cell which have
been shown to be really important in
type 2 information both in Feldman's
infection and allergic disease and so
i'm coming to you today from the Baker
Institute for Animal Health and the
Department of Microbiology and
immunology at Cornell University the
College of Veterinary Medicine and I
look forward to answering any questions
that anybody has at the end of the
presentation so first of all I'll give
just a very brief background on innate
lymphoid cells in general and
particularly the group 2 innate lymphoid
cells so many of you
I already have a background in this cell
type but I'd like to provide some broad
information for those who are new to the
field so the innate lymphoid cells or
I'll sees as I'll refer to them are a
rare type of innate immune cell at
recent studies have shown that these
cell types are important in mediating
protective immune responses causing
inflammation and mediating tissue repair
and also metabolic homeostasis
particularly at barrier surfaces so
these cells are enriched not only in
lymphoid tissues but also at mucosal
surfaces such as the intestine the lung
and also in the skin and so these cells
are relatively recently identified and
part of the reason that they were not
identified previously is that again they
are quite rare but they are also
negative for expression of many of the
so-called lineage markers that we stain
for using flow cytometry and you know
histah chemistry and other techniques so
what do I mean by this so specifically
these cell types do not express markers
of T cells B cells and kay sells
granulocytes such as neutrophils and
myeloid cells like macrophages and
dendritic cells so they are negative for
a wide array of different markers that
mark the various lineages of immune
cells however these cells can be
positively identified by their
expression of certain cytokine receptors
such as cd25 the il-2 receptor alpha CD
127 part of the receptor for il-7 and
also the aisle 33 receptor and there are
three major subsets of these cells that
have been highlighted and these subsets
are heterogeneous in their phenotype and
function and in fact are analogous to
the T helper cell subsets however keep
in mind these cells are not
antigen-specific and they lack a t-cell
receptor and so this diagram provides
sort of a brief overview of the
different subsets
I'll seize that have been identified so
the group one I LCS which include
classical and K cells and then also a
separate branch of t-bet dependent
interferon gamma producing innate
lymphoid cells and recent work has shown
that classical NK cells and these I'll
see ones are in fact divergent
populations that come from different
progenitors then I'll skip down for a
moment to highlight the group three ilcs
and so these cells again come from a
particular dedicated precursor they
express the transcription factor ror
gamma T and produce cytokines such as
I'll 22 and il-17 and then of course the
group 2 i'll CS which will focus on
today are dependent upon transcription
factors such as gala 3 & R R alpha and
these cells have been highlighted for
their ability to produce type 2
cytokines like aisle five I'll 13 also
aisle 9 and the growth factor and for
regulon and so again we'll focus in
today on the group 2 ilcs and a bit more
on these cells and their background what
we know and what we don't these cells
were initially identified in the context
of intestinal helminth infection and
also in fat associated lymphoid clusters
and so these cells have been shown to
promote type tuning responses during
helminth infection and also allergic
disease and they also play key roles in
maintaining tissue homeostasis and
repair and also metabolic homeostasis so
similar to other I'll see subsets I LLC
2's are activated by the epithelial cell
derived cytokines that they encounter in
their environment and these can include
I'll 25 I'll 33 and TS LP they also
respond to aisle 2 in Aisle seven and as
you can see here on the little schematic
on the left of your screen
the ilc Zarda pet the ilc 2's are
dependent upon gayathri ror alpha they
express these cytokine receptors and
also the thigh antigen cv 90 and they
produce aisle five aisle nine mile 13
and the growth factor-alpha regulon and
so what I'd like to do today is
highlight some of the challenges that I
and others have encountered in the
analysis of these cells so these are a
rare cell type and thus there are some
relatively unique challenges in terms of
assessing these salts phenotypically and
functionally and so I'm going to go
through and highlight a number of the
technical challenges that one might
encounter when assessing the role of
these cells in various models and then
also some technical approaches that I've
been able to use successfully in order
to examine these cells and so I'll just
highlight very briefly the three
challenges that I'll go through today so
the first challenge is that as I
mentioned before these cells are rare
and they tend to be enriched in non
lymphoid tissues and so one approach
that i have used to meet this challenge
is to utilize multicolored flow
cytometry to assess these cells ex vivo
in non lymphoid tissues a second
challenge that I'd like to highlight is
that the tools and reagents to assess
these cells really remain in development
this is a very fast-moving field and we
don't really know everything yet about
these cells phenotypically and
functionally which makes looking at
these souls very exciting but also
technically challenging and so one
approach that I'll highlight to meet
this challenge is the use of the prime
flow RNAs a available through
ebioscience that enables single-cell RNA
staining based on flow cytometric
approach and then finally another
challenge is that because these cells
are incompletely characterized the in
vivo readouts to examine their function
are really not standardized and not all
of the techniques that we use for
instance to look at T cells have been
validated
SI toos and so I'll talk a little bit
about two different technical approaches
to look at ilc to function the first is
sorting these cells and using in vitro
functional assays and then the second
approach is using knockout mouse models
and I'll see to transfer systems to
begin to look at ilc to function in vivo
and so what I'd like to do today is
utilize sort of a case study one
particular project that was just
completed when I was a postdoctoral
fellow with dr. David artists looking at
the role of the prostaglandin d2 pathway
in regulating I'll see two responses
during type to inflammation and so these
studies were recently published in you
coastal immunology so I invite you to
please review that publication and I'm
going to use some of the figures and
approaches that were utilized in that
manuscript to sort of highlight some of
these challenges and technical
approaches that we were able to use to
take a look at ilc to phenotype of the
function in a model of type 2
inflammation and so first I need to give
you just a brief background on
prostaglandin d2 and how this pathway
works so prostaglandin d2 like other
eicosanoids is a bioactive lipid it is
produced during the steady state but in
the context of allergic inflammation and
type 2 inflammation in general
production of PG d 2 is hugely increased
this molecule has two receptors that are
expressed by various cell types one of
them is called CRT h2 or chemoattractant
receptor homologue of homologous
molecule expressed on th2 cells and
initial studies from harrigan spits and
other labs highlighted that human ilc
tues expressed CRT h2 and initially the
function of CRT h2 expression by these
cells was unclear and so a couple of
other pieces of information that are
used
people to know regarding this pathway
PTD to is largely produced by mast cells
it's thought although macrophages may
also be a source and ligation of CRT h2
x prostaglandin d2 leads to
internalization of the receptor and then
activation of the cells so this
activation entails cell migration and
also cytokine production and cells that
express CRT h2 in addition to the ilc
2's include eosinophils basophils and
some mast cells and this pathway the PJD
to see our th2 pathway has previously
been strongly associated with type 2
inflammation especially in the one and
recent studies had also highlighted an
important role for ilc choose in the
lung and so we hypothesized that the PJD
to see our tht pathway might regulate
ilc to migration activation or
accumulation during type to inflammation
in the lung and so this is the case
study that I'll use today to illustrate
some of the techniques for assessing the
ilc tues so the first question that I'd
like to highlight as part of this
project was we wanted to know whether
there were any tissue specific
differences in the pattern of CR THQ
expression in human I'll see cheese and
so one challenge here is well why are we
looking at human aisles to choose well
the answer to that is that there is an
antibody that recognizes CR th2 in
humans but such an antibody does not
exist in mice and so we wanted to take a
look at expression patterns of this
receptor on human IOC choose to
determine whether there was any tissue
specific regulation of this pathway and
so the challenge here is that in humans
as in mice and other species IL c 2 s
are a rare cell type and are enriched in
on one floyd tissues and so as i
mentioned previously in the outline our
technical approach here is to utilize a
multi-colored flow cytometry analysis to
look at these
and so what we did here was utilize
human tissues from previously healthy
adult organ donors and so these tissues
were made available through a
collaboration with dr. Donna Farber at
Columbia University who collects these
tissues in collaboration with the New
York organ donor network and so first of
all I just like to show you that in
human peripheral blood we can identify a
population of cells which is lineage
negative so using closed cytometry it
does not express markers of t cells B
cells and kay sells myeloid cells or
granulocytes and I have some information
here on the bottom of the slide that
indicates some of the specific markers
that are in our lineage gates and so you
can use that as a reference and anyway
these cells are lineage negative and a
proportion of them express CD 127 the
aisle 7 receptor and that's shown here
in this plot from the left if we gain on
these cells a proportion of them also
express the il-33 receptor and so these
cells then have a phenotype consistent
with that of IL c 2 s lineage negative
CD 127 positive and il-33 receptor
positive then using the antibody that's
available against humans ER th to that
we can identify a population of cells
that expresses CR th to from amongst
these IL c 2 s and this is a large
proportion of these cells that are
positive however interestingly when we
look in the human lung we can again
identify a population of cells that has
a phenotype consistent with that of
ayala SI toos however when we look at CR
th2 expression it's much lower on these
lung ilc tues then on the blood I'll see
tues and so this is shown graphically
here and the lines connect samples from
the same donor and so you can see in a
matched set from the same donor that
I'll see choose from the blood express
higher levels in general of CRT h2
hair to those in the lung and so these
data suggest that indeed there is
tissue-specific heterogeneity of CR th
to expression by these human ayala SI
toos suggesting that potentially this
pathway may play a role in either the
distribution of cells amongst tissues or
their regulation of migration or
activation and so the next question that
we wanted to ask is are these
differences conserved in mice and so can
we use the murine model to then ask
experimental questions about the role of
this pathway and as I mentioned a couple
slides ago unfortunately there's
currently no antibody available that
recognizes neurons ER th 2 so we are not
able to use classical antibody-based
detection of this molecule on these
neuronal SI toos and so this really
highlights one of the other major
challenges and looking at these cells is
that the tools and reagents to assess
I'll see tues remain in development and
one technical approach that I was able
to utilize to answer this question and
meet this challenge was to utilize
ebioscience 'as pro prime flow RNA assay
which is a single cell RNA staining
approach and so i'm not going to talk
about the technical details of this
assay today however i would refer you to
the ebioscience website they have a
wealth of information on this essay its
design troubleshooting and other pieces
of information that are very useful so
if you're interested in learning more
about how this assay works or
incorporating it into your own studies
then I really encourage you to visit the
website and also give ebioscience a call
technical support is very helpful and so
I'd like to show you that using this
approach which i think the strength of
it really is that you can simultaneously
use antibody-based stating for proteins
using flow cytometry as you normally
would and then also couple that with a
single cell RNA transcript staining
approach that allows you to identify
cells using
cytometry and then look at expression of
particular genes or the presence of
certain transcripts in those cells and
so this approach allowed me to be able
to take a look at ilc choose and then
look at gene expression for GPR 44 which
is the gene that encodes for CRT h2 and
so here in this top panel using the
prime flow RNAs a I can utilize flow
cytometry and antibody-based staining to
identify I'll see tues in the peripheral
blood of mice and so these cells again
our lineage negative they express CD 127
and also the thigh antigen which is used
in mice to identify these cells and a
proportion of these cells also express
the 33 receptors so these cells are ilc
tues then using the prime flow RNAs a I
can identify that a large proportion
greater than half of these IL c 2 s are
positive for expression of GPR 40 for
the gene that encodes for CRT h2 and so
I'm going to take a moment in the next
slide to talk about some of the
technical controls and approaches here
so i will get back to that in a second
and so these data in the peripheral
blood are consistent with what i
observed in humans that a significant
proportion of the ilc to population in
the blood is positive for GPR 44
expression and then again similarly to
what I observed in humans when I look in
the mirror and lung again I can identify
I'll see to like cells that are lineage
negative CD 90ct 127 and I'll 33
receptor positive but mirroring what is
seen in the human GPR 44 expression of
these cells is quite low and that's
shown here and so these data really
suggest that patterns of GPR 44
expression that are observed to have a
tissue-specific heterogeneity are really
conserved in mice and in humans which
nicely validates the use of murine
models to take a look at the role of the
PJD to CRT
h2 pathway in mice and so I want to take
just a moment to talk about some of the
controls and technical approaches for
the prime flow a say that I found very
helpful that I'd like to share and so
first I guess really what what I'd like
to convey is that this assay has great
power to allow you to really look at
things that you wouldn't be able to
otherwise however like every other flow
cytometry experiment controls are key in
order to enable a successful analysis
and data that are interpreted and there
are a couple of controls that are unique
to this assay so I'll highlight one of
those controls first and that's a
positive control for RNA skating and so
the recommendation from ebioscience is
to utilize a housekeeping gene so to
speak however these housekeeping genes
aren't utilized in the same way as you
would in quantitative real-time pcr for
example but instead function as a
positive control for successful staining
of cells and so in my experiments I
utilize beta 2 microglobulin as a
positive control there are other options
and technical support at a bio can be
very helpful in working with you to
select an appropriate control for your
assay and tissue and so looking both in
the peripheral blood here on the left
and in the lung here on the right I
utilized staining for beta 2 m and this
is in the Alexa 750 channel to identify
cells that were positive for RNA
transcripts for the beta 2 m so these
cells have been successfully fixed and
permeabilized and stained using the
protocol these cells are also
transcriptionally active and so a key
part of using this positive control is
to also have a built in negative control
and so that's a fluorescence minus 1
staining control for beta 2 m and so in
this standing control I'm getting the
same way as I do
here in my fully stay instant sample but
this sample here on the right lacks the
probe for beta to em so we know that
this sample is negative for beta 2 m
because we didn't put the program and so
that allows us to them set the gate
based on any back background
fluorescence that then allows for the
successful identification of positively
stained cells and I'd like to point out
that the gates between the peripheral
blood and the lung are in fact different
so just like flow cytometry using
antibodies there are different levels of
background and autofluorescence in
different tissues and so it's important
to perform this control in the different
tissues that you're utilizing and so
this is a great positive control to
ensure that your cells that you're
analyzing have been successfully fixed
and permeabilized that they're actually
transcriptionally active cells and that
provides a great basis for moving
forward in the analysis then the second
type of control that I'd like to
highlight is one that you would use
routinely in normal flow cytometry but
one that is particularly important in
the prime flow assay which is the use of
negative staining controls for the
protein staining or a fluorescence minus
one FMO controls or isotype controls
depending upon your preference and the
suitability for either control or what
you're staining before and so here in
this panel again in either the blood on
the left or the lung on the right I'm
using fluorescence minus one controls to
set gate four on the plots on the left
CD 1 27 in PE and then in the plots on
the right the idle 33 receptor in PE
size 7 and so you can see based on the
axes here that I've set the gate based
on the negative or lack of staining in
this fluorescence minus one control and
so this allows me to ensure that like in
every other flow cytometry experiment
that the population I'm dating on is
truly positive and so these two
important controls I think really set
the stage for success with the prime
flow assay the cells in the process and
I'm just like when you do intracellular
cytokine staining look somewhat
different than they do when run fresh so
it's very important to perform these
controls in order to set yourself up for
success ok so now moving on I just want
to show a very quick validation of the
prime flow data that i just showed so i
was able to use reverse transcriptase
pcr for GPR 44 to identify in sort
purified I'll see choose as shown in the
schematic here that when this is run on
a gel I can identify that ilc tubes are
positive for expression of GPR 44 and
here I'm using long eosinophils as a
positive control and so using this
traditional technique to look at
expression of a gene or the presence of
transcripts in this purified cell type I
can validate my data from the prime flow
assay ok so then moving on to the next
question that I really wanted to address
in this project I had established that
there was tissue specific heterogeneity
in the ilc to population based on CR th
to expression and so again this might
suggest that there's a role for the PG
to see rth to in regulating I'll see to
migration between tissues accumulation
in tissues etc so the next question I
wanted to ask was does this pathway
regulate I'll see to migration and the
challenge here is that the readouts in
vivo especially for looking at migration
to examine I LLC tube function are
really not standardized and haven't been
fully described and so one technical
approach is to utilize cell sorting and
purification of these cells and then in
vitro functional assays to learn more
about how these cells function and so
the first approach that I utilized was
an in vitro key
taxes a say and so in this assay
wild-type animals are treated with
recombinant neuron il-33 and this is to
expand the ilc to population to enable
relatively straightforward sorting so
this expands the population which is
quite important because this is a rare
population and sorting out of a
steady-state mouse can be very
challenging so this approach allows for
the expansion of the ilc to population
and then the successful sort
purification of these cells and so these
cells are lineage negative cd9 be
positive cd25 positive and then also
positive for CB 127 and the il-33
receptor and the cells i'm showing here
are from the lung for this assay i
purified not only cells from the
mirroring one but also cells from the
spleen i couldn't use the blood in this
assay as i had in previous mira SI is
because I Oct use in the blood are
really too rare even with the aisle 33
treatment to sort readily it's possible
but challenging and so here I sorted
I'll see tubes from the lung and the
spleen and I subjected these cells to an
in vitro chemotaxis assay where I placed
ilc tues in the top of a transwell and
then placed prostaglandin d2 in the
bottom of the transwell and asked after
90 minutes how many of these cells
migrate and what I found was that lung
I'll see choose from mice migrate rather
poorly in response to PG be too however
I LC choose from the spleen migrate
somewhat more efficiently and these data
are I think consistent with what I
observed in the flow cytometry staining
in the human and also using the prime
flow a say in mice in that receptor
expression is higher in peripheral ilc
tues versus those from the lungs so it
would make sense that these cells from
the periphery are better able to respond
to ligand or PG t 2 and so this assay
demonstrates that we can utilize cells
swear
and then in vitro functional assay is to
take a look at what these cells can do
functionally another approach I utilized
was to look at whether or not these
purified IL c 2 s could produce cytokine
in response to PG d 2 and so for this
assay to expand the ilc to populations
instead of vile 33 treatments i was able
to utilize aisle 7 complexes and so this
injection of her common in Aisle seven
protein in conjunction with an anti
aisle 7 antibody leads to IL c 2
expansion in the absence of activation
and so I'll 33 treated IL c 2 s are
somewhat activated whereas aisle 7
complex treated I'll see choose are less
activated but still expand it and so
this again allows for the sort
purification of these cells and then in
vitro culture with either cytokines or
prostaglandin d2 to then assess cytokine
production using either Eliza or
intracellular cytokines dating and so
here I'm just showing you Eliza data
from culture of these cells after 48
hours and so on the bottom you can see
the different treatments for the cells
and then I'm showing aisle 5 on the left
and I off 13 on the right and what I'd
like to highlight here is that as
previously described culture with either
I'll 25 or I'll 33 leads to an induction
of il-5 production and also aisle 13
production however interestingly culture
with pge 2 does not really lead to a
significant increase in these cytokines
so that can be observed here in these
two bars and in addition a coat culture
with the cytokine + PG d 2 does not
really lead to much of a synergy and so
that's shown here there's a small
increase here and then looking at aisle
13 there is no
synergy and so these data suggest that
me Ryan ilc choose produce relatively
low levels of cytokines in vitro in
response to prostaglandin now keep in
mind that these ilc choose i'm showing
here are from the lawn then so it's
possible that i'll see choose from the
spleen or other peripheral organs might
produce more cytokine in response to PG
d to consistent with their increased
expression of CR tht so intracellular
cytokine staining can also be used with
these cells to assess cytokine
production and so here i'm just showing
you a multivariate analysis looking at
production of three different cytokines
by ICS and these are il-5 aisle nine and
il-13 and the different colors and the
pie wedges demonstrate whether the cells
are producing 0 1 2 or 3 different
cytokines and then the bars around the
outside of the pies are showing actually
what cytokine the cells are producing so
similar to the Eliza data of what you
can appreciate here is that well I'll 25
in Aisle 33 lead to significant changes
in intracellular cytokine detection
compared to what we see in the media PGD
to culture does not really elicit a
large change in the cytokine production
profile of these cells there are some
changes for instance there's in a slight
increase in the number of cells that are
producing 1 cytokine rather than none
but these changes aren't really
significant so these data are consistent
with the Eliza data but these two assays
really demonstrate that one can utilize
standard Eliza's and also intracellular
cytokine stadium using antibodies for me
bioscience to measure cytokine
production and functionality of these
cells in vitro okay and then the final
set of data that I'd like to show you is
addressing the question of whether or
not this pathway the PJD to CR tht
halfway can regulate LLC to accumulation
and type 2 inflammation in the lung in
vivo and so again the challenge that
we're dealing with here is that in vivo
readouts to examine I'll see to function
are not always defined are technically
challenging and are not standardized and
so the approach that I'd like to
highlight here is the use of knockout
mouse models in ilc to transfer
approaches to begin to look at the
functional role of ilc choose in vivo so
first of all the initial experiment that
I wanted to perform here is to ask
whether I'll see tues will accumulate in
the lung in vivo in response to PG b2 at
all so in a very simple system I
utilized wild-type mice and then animals
that were CR th to knock out or GPR 44
deficient I treated these animals with
PGD to intranasally for three days and
then on day three I asked do I Elsie
choose accumulate in the lung and is
this accumulation if it occurs dependent
upon CRT h2 and so what I found was yes
indeed if we look at immune cells
isolated from the lung of these mice
that were treated with either PBS is
controlled or PG d 2 then in wild-type
animals there is an increase in the
number of IL c 2 s in the lung following
administration of PGD to intranasally
notably this number was significantly
decreased in animals that lacked CRT h2
and so these data suggest that in vivo
IOC tues can accumulate in the mirror
and in response to pge 2 and this occurs
in a CRT h2 dependent manner ok so then
the next question is that's sort of a
artificial system in a way administering
prostaglandin directly into the lung so
in the context of a more physiological
model of type 2 inflammation in the lung
can we also see evidence of the same
role for the PG
to see our tht pathway and I'll see twos
and so the model that we used here was a
taking advantage of the rodent parasite
new poster Angeles braziliensis so I'll
give you just a few brief words of
background on this parasite and the
model that we've used here and so nippes
crown jealous is a rat parasite it's
rodent adapted mouse adapted so it can
be used in your own models it infects
through the skin shown here and that
allows it to enter the circulation of
the host then it migrates through the
circulation and bursts out into the lung
and so the larvae of the parasite then
migrate through the lung and are
ultimately coughed up and swallowed and
that's how the parasite larvae and make
their way to the small intestine which
is their final home where they become
fully mature adults and where they
reproduce and so a couple of notes on
this model type to inflammation is
elicited by the migration at the poster
Angeles at a number of different points
in tissues and so there's inflammation
in the skin there's also inflammation
that develops in the lung and then
there's type to information that
develops which is protective and helps
to expel parasites in the small
intestine and so the model or the
portion of the model that I focused on
was what occurs here in the lung and so
interestingly immunocompetent mice are
able to expel this parasite from the
small intestine by day 10 postinfection
so all of the parasites are completely
gone from these animals by j10 however
the migration of the parasites through
the lung during the early stages of
infection lead to a long lasting chronic
type to inflammatory response in the
pulmonary tissues and so here on the
Left panel on day 30 postinfection mice
that had been infected with nicko stron
jealous developed this emphysematous
like pathology and info
in the lung and this is really
accompanied by all of the hallmarks of
type 2 inflammation so there are
increased via sinha fills there's
increased type to cytokine production
and so here I'm showing aisle 13 and
it's quite interesting well some of
these responses do quiet down over time
this pathology in the type to signature
that can be observed are really
persistent for the life of the mouse so
in the absence of parasites this type to
inflammation in the lung is indeed
chronic and so we can utilize this model
to then take a look at how the PGP to
see our th2 pathway my influence I don't
see two responses during chronic type to
inflammation in the womb and so the
experiment I performed was again to
utilize this setup to infect either
wild-type or CR th to knockout mice with
end brasiliensis and then look at day 30
and similar to what is shown what I
showed previously wild-type animals
develop an intensive and feminist like
pathology and infiltrate in the lung an
interestingly GPR 44 knockout mice are
significantly protected so I'm not
showing the data here but if we utilize
a scoring system to score this pathology
for emphysema tsk ethology and also for
cell infiltration there is a significant
reduction in the pathology score in the
knockout mice compared to the wild type
in addition if I look at other
parameters of type 2 inflammation in the
lung in here and showing gene expression
for il-4 in the lung tissues you'll note
that infection with nip astragalus in
the wild-type leads to a strong
induction of vile for expression which
is abrogated in the absence of CRT h2
and so tracking with this I'll for data
and if you look at gene expression for
aisle 13 if we look at accumulation of
immune cells including
else you choose cd4 t-cells and
infiltrating monocytes we can see that
this pattern is really maintained and so
nippes Tron jealous elicits a response
in wild-type animals and deficiency in
CRT h2 is protective in this model and
so then the question arises of okay we
know that CRT h2 plays a role in
promoting the inflammation in this
comment induced model of type 2
pulmonary inflammation but what cell
types are actually expressing the CRT h2
that's important in mediating the
phenotype and is it in fact the ilc tues
and so I took two different approaches
to start to assess the role of ilc to
intrinsic CRT h2 expression and so the
first I'm going to describe to you is a
bone marrow chimera model and so what I
did here was a radiate congenic
wild-type mice so these animals have a
wild-type non-hematopoietic compartment
and then performed a bone marrow
transplant with a 50-50 mix of congenic
we marked wild-type ilc tues MTP r44
deficient i'll see cheese and so i can
utilize flow cytometry to stay for the
kinetic workers to identify the origin
of the odyssey tues in these chimeric
animals these animals are then infected
with new post Ron jealous and then at
d32 post-infection I can ask whether
wild-type CR th to express theme i ll c
2 s or the GPR 44 deficient knockout IL
c 2 s get into the inflamed one and so
using flow cytometry i can then identify
the alcy cheese in the lung and look at
their origin and so here you can see
that overwhelmingly by frequency and
this plot is gated on total ilc choose
that IL c 2 s that are wild type where
express CR th two are better at getting
to the lung then knockout IOC choose and
so these cells the wild types your teach
to expressing
have a competitive advantage in this
model these data are consistent when we
look at the total number of IL cts in
the lung and so following infection the
total number of wild wild type CR teach
to expressing Alice tattoos is greater
than knockout I'll see cheese and so
these data suggest that CR th to
expression lends a competitive advantage
to ioc choose to getting into the lung
in the context of this helminth induced
type to inflammation so that only really
answers part of the question and so the
last piece of data and the last approach
that I'd like to show you is utilizing
an adoptive transfer model in order to
assess functionally how a CR th to
expressing population of IL c 2 s
influences the development of type 2
information of pathology in this model
so here in this experimental setup I
again have wild-type and knockout
animals and then I have a third group of
CR th two knockout mice which are
supplemented every seven days throughout
the course of infection with wild-type
CR th to expressing I'll see cheese and
so the only cell types the only cell
type in these mines that actually
express CR th two are these transfer
denial SI toos and so at this
experimental design that allows me to
look out again at day 30 to post
infection in the lung to determine what
the functional role of a CR th to
expressing IL c 2 is in the context of
this in vivo model and just to validate
that this experimental system works in
the lung of recipient knockout mice at
day 32 i can identify cells that were
transferred in based on congenic marker
expression so that's shown here these
cells are CD 45.1 positive further
gating reveals that these cells have a
phenotype consistent with that a vile SI
toos so they express CD 127 and the
il-33 receptor so they remain IL c 2 s
and then when these cells are stimulated
with PMA and on iono meissen they
produce large quantities of il-13 so
these transferred cells then can be
identified in the lung of the recipient
they still look like i'll see twos and
they do what I also tues do validating
that this transfer model is successful
and so then what does the pathology and
type 2 information look like in these
mice that received transferred IL c 2 s
so again as before knockout animals are
partially protected from the development
of pathology and inflammation following
and brasiliensis infection compared to
the wild type and then i'll draw our
attention here to the bottom panel c r
th to knockout mice that received crh to
sufficient ilc tues now have pathology
in the lung very similar to that
observed in the wild-type mice and these
data are mirrored when we look at the
type to gene expression in the lung so
again GPR 44 knockout animals following
infection are protected however the
transfer of CR th to expressing IL c 2 s
then renders these animals again
susceptible to this type to information
and so these data suggest that really
the presence of CR th to expressing ilc
tunes alone is sufficient to drive this
fulminant type to pulmonary inflammation
okay so I'll just take a moment to
summarize some of the data that I've
discussed today and so using this case
study of investigating the role of PGD 2
and C are th 2 on the functional role of
ioc tues in the lung during type to
inflammation and these data suggest that
CR th to expressing IL c 2 s respond to
PG d 2 derived from potentially mouse
cells or macrophages to accumulate in
the lung tissue and then subsequently
the presence of these cells in the lung
tissue lead to the accumulation or
infiltration of other cell
in the inflamed one production of type 2
cytokines and the development of lung
pathology and disease and so um I think
to go back to talk about some of the
challenges that I highlighted and I hope
that this model was very instructive in
helping some of you think about
different ways that you can analyze
these rare cell types different
approaches that you could utilize for
not only in vitro analysis but also ex
vivo and in vivo approaches and I think
that looking at these cell types is is
really important and fascinating and
that the technical challenges can
actually be easily met working with
partners like you bioscience and
particularly thinking a little bit about
the prime flow assays for certain
technical approaches and from which
there are no antibodies or for which
there are challenges in traditional flow
cytometry and so with that I'll be happy
to take any questions either regarding
the science of the project that I
highlighted today or some of the
technical approaches that I discussed in
looking at the analyses of ilc tues and
I just before we do that I just like to
acknowledge a number of people first of
all members in my laboratory which I've
just started here at Cornell and I'm
very excited about also I'd like to
thank friends at ebioscience including
Peggy just Castle foo nataka and Matt
Jeff on odilon who's been a great help
and also basil and for assistance with
this webinar and and other activities
and they've been really great and very
supportive also a big thank you to my
formal former postdoctoral mentor David
artists and the team at Weill Cornell in
his lab these individuals were really
instrumental in putting together the set
of data and the PGC r th to project also
collaborators at amgen and donna Farber
Jerome at Columbia University and so
with that I again will be happy to take
any questions I look forward to hearing
what everybody has to say and thanks so
much for tuning in thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how this with questions you can submit
questions by typing them in a Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question from Lucy golden Mason at
the University of Colorado is how many
PB MCS do you need to stain to get good
plots of ilc 22 I'll see choose thanks
for that question Lucy so it depends on
whether you're looking at mouse or human
I have found that actually humans have a
somewhat lower frequency of ilc tues in
the blood then do mice so for humans I
like to try and stain out of at least
three to five million pbmc s4 mice I
think you can get by with a little bit
lower but i would still aim for at least
three million pbmc s so you almost have
to take all of the blood from a single
mouse to get a good I'll see to plot the
the peripheral blood is a bit difficult
because the ilc cheese are more rare
certainly in the mouse we know a little
bit less about the human because we're
not able to look at all of the different
mucosal tissues and but you do need to
look at a relatively large number of
starting cells
Klaus pickled from bio spider
technologies asks how do you sort viable
mounts I'll see two for rt-pcr in the
absence of an ad for GTR 44 thanks for
that question so for the rt-pcr analysis
that I showed those IL c 2 s were sorted
as lineage negative CD 90 positive cd25
positive and I'll 33 receptor positive
so me ryan IL c 2 s can really be
identified quite well based on their
expression of the aisle 33 receptor
that's been established by a number of
groups and so those sort purified cells
are then I'll 33 receptor positive ilc
choose that I then looked for gene
expression of GPR 44 both using rt-pcr
and then also using whole blood or lung
using the prime flow RNAs a Christina's
feel from the German rheumatism Research
Center asks how do you define your CR th
two positive cells for transfer without
using prime flow Christina that's a
great question so in those transfer
experiments the population of alc choose
that I transferred in I really don't
know what percentage of them RCR th to
positive or not I only know that they
came from wild-type CR th to competent
mice if you will so a more precise
experiment obviously would be to
transfer in only those aisles to choose
that RC r th to positive so at this
point without an antibody prime flow is
really the only way to ID
to buy those cells but because prime
flow then kills the cells you can't use
that as as a method to identify CR th to
positive ilc choose so that experiment I
think could certainly be refined and
that's a that's a great question um
Frank Fassbender of IFA do asks how have
you approached characterizing
Judy could you repeat that question you
cut out please thank you please thank
you sure i'm actually going to skip to
another question first and then we'll
get to that one if that's k gene a lean
of Regeneron asks do you see any
difference in st to expression in blood
versus lung yeah great question the
answer is yes there does seem to be
tissue specific differences in st to
expression both in humans and in mice in
mice i have found certainly that 33
receptor expression in the lung tends to
be higher than what we see in the blood
and that's true but less pronounced in
humans so there certainly are
tissue-specific or there is
tissue-specific heterogeneity in Aisle
33 receptor expression as well and i
have found it very useful when i'm doing
flow cytometric staining for il-33 in
those different tissues to utilize an
MMO control to make sure that i'm really
gating accurately on the positive cells
in those different tissues how I pay me
by of harvard medical school asks any
aisles I'll see cells produce aisle 10
and gtf tgf-b yeah that's
it's an interesting question to my
knowledge it has not been reported that
large amounts of isleton or tgf-beta are
produced by ilc subsets so for instance
at least to date to my knowledge there
has not been highlighted a regulatory
I'll see population although that cell
population may certainly be out there
and in my own experience some ALCS
whether they be I'll see twos or threes
I haven't really looked much at once
they can produce a little bit of aisle
10 following p mañana meissen i have not
looked at tgf-beta but that's something
that i think is somewhat wide open in
the literature Rebecca Ingram of queen's
university belfast says it's interesting
their differences between lung and blood
are there also differences in the
expression of lung homing chemokine
receptors such as ccr6 rebecca great
question i have not stained for
chemokine receptors in the same panels
that i have looked at CRT h2 in humans
for instance now a 33 receptor so i
don't really know and that analysis is
certainly possible utilizing multi color
flow cytometry but i have not done those
analyses and at least off the top of my
head i can't think of another analysis
that's really looked at chemokine
receptors in comparing different tissues
okay bear with me just a second here we
have questions coming in one second here
but see you're with me one second i'm
having a little technological glitch
here that I we have more questions and i
will ask another question in just a
second Taylor Doherty of UCSD asks sorry
for my technological problem here Taylor
Taylor Doherty of UCSD asks do you see
any difference I'm sorry he asks pge2
has been shown to wrap rapidly highly
induce th2 cytokines in human ilc choose
what do you think accounts with the
difference between mouse and human yeah
great great question and that was
something that was actually surprising
to me and that the mir eine else you
choose didn't really produce a lot of
cytokines in contrast to the human and
so one thing that i think is important
to keep in mind is that in mice at least
by the prime flow assay the lung ilc
choose our are very low express errs for
GPR 44c rth to even though the
transcript comes up using rt-pcr using
the prime flow assay the transcript
level is really low and so I think those
cells in mice anyway don't have a lot of
capacity to respond to PG d two v OC r
th two and those cytokine analyses that
i showed we're from lung purified ilc
tues and so I did some pilot assays
looking at I'll see choose from the
spleen and their responsiveness in
cytokine
action following PGD to treatment and
they actually do appear to produce more
more similarly to what's been shown for
humans but I frankly haven't repeated
that experiment enough to really say for
sure and so I think what we see in the
lung I'll see choose of mice in terms of
the lack of cytokine production in
response to PG d 2 is really a function
of their very low C or th2 or GPR 44
expression and further analyses are
really necessary to compare Mouse versus
human I'll see choose in different
tissues and how they might respond to PG
d to visa V cytokine production we run
out of time I would like to thank our
sponsor ebioscience for making today's
educational webcast possible if we did
not get to your question today will
respond in the next couple of days
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
this year will receive an email from lab
boots alerting me when this webcast will
be available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time bye